honestly it was such a good party and it
is so fun and it felt like literally it
felt like a wedding Eminem's daughter
Haley Jade celebrates her engagement
with an epic bash the food was
incredible never had a better grilled
cheese in my whole life they had a late
night snack option oh we are doing the
late night snack we're setting the bar
really high but before her fiance Evan
McClintock got down on bended knee he
asked her famous dad for his Blessing I
saw your dad go downstairs I'm like all
right this I gotta do it right now Haley
and Evan got engaged back in February
but waited until April to celebrate with
family and friends I really wanted to be
a surprise I fully believed it I thought
we're together all the time I will
freaking notice if you're like up to
something even telling people after when
they asked me like were you surprised I
definitely was
shocked and surprised Haley dished about
the party which took place at a glass
Penthouse in Detroit on her podcast just
a little shady the venue that we went to
that was kind of the setup of their menu
was meant for like wedding events so
they did you know past stuff in the
beginning that you had the main food
every time I turned around they were
artichini meatballs this is sick this is
so nice Haley teased that she had
multiple outfits for the event during a
get ready with me on Instagram leading
up to the party I'm going pretty natural
on the eye makeup because I'm actually
doing a few outfit changes and gave fans
a look at one of the fits on Tick Tock
okay engagement party off of like the
quickest fit check ever because I am
literally at the place and I'm late to
my own party somehow so gotta go bye as
for why they waited so long to celebrate
I am super excited for this evening
because we actually got engaged like
three months ago but we wanted to plan
like kind of a big engagement party Evan
popped the question back in February and
in a recently resurfaced episode of her
podcast Evan revealed he asked Eminem
for permission to marry his daughter
back in December on Haley's birthday was
that holiday yeah over the holidays I uh
I was just looking for like uh you know
an opportunity not to make it too
obvious and I didn't notice but didn't
you say it was like you guys went to get
like my cake or something this is for my
birthday yeah yeah I saw your dad go
downstairs I'm like all right this I
gotta do it right now or am I doing it
today I'm gonna have to like schedule
some other time and uh so I just
followed him downstairs and thankfully
he was just down there grabbing your
cake well looks like the rapper gave
Evan his Blessing and these two are
ready to live happily ever after
[Music]
thank you